we want him to be the ring bearer so i'm
hoping he'll walk straight to data with
the rings i think he will yeah but he
gets over on overwhelm with a big crowd
i thought my guest list was going to be
100 and it's well over that
two people who won't be attending
artem's parents they live in russia and
artem says it's equivalent to impossible
to get them to the u.s for the ceremony
so we are hoping
that we're going to do something cute
via zoom
because we are so sad that they can't
come and um
artem goes just don't make it too big of
a scream and i feel like i told my go
you know we your dancer and i feel like
we really have to have great
entertainment like we both are in the
entertainment business and so we've
already kind of gone back and forth
about a few things there
which hopefully one day i could share
about oh well we're gonna have some fun
surprises at our wedding before nicki
and artem's i do's only we were with her
and twin brie at margaritaville for a
live taping of the bellas podcast they
recorded their mother's day episode for
siriusxm stitcher with guest kristen
cavallari i'm so excited to be here hi
guys
and shared with us their special plans
for the big day artem and i are finally
going to be moving into our new home
that we've been working on building for
the past year and a half so it's kind of
cool because this mother's day just
marks like
kind of like the first place where we're
just coming together as a family almost
officially and just get to grow in this
new home so it's going to be definitely
a special one for me i'll be at
disneyland with birdie it'll be kind of
like a fun mother-daughter trip so i'm
excited for that birdie turns five the
day after mother's day while bree's
buddy and nicki's mateo are almost two
yeah the milestone recently i feel like
i've gone through is like mateo is
really showing us what he wants or what
he doesn't want i mean he's made it very
clear to artem and i he does not want to
sleep in a onesie so i was like online
like ordering like crazy like okay two
pieces get him two pieces and that's
what he wants to wear yeah and he's not
even two as for baby number two for me
no
um i think artem hopes for something
different and wishes for that and you
never know what the future can hold but
i don't see that happening anytime soon
god i hope not
i'm so tired but not tired enough to
count out a wwe return we definitely
have it in us i don't know when it'll be
when we get more sleep with the boys
yeah right hey i want to do it
and the 38 year old mamas aren't opposed
to their little ones following in their
parents footsteps for sure the
danielsons will be in the ring the other
day i'm not even kidding i'm making
lunch and i look over and buddy's on the
coffee table jumping onto the couch like
a flying squirrel and i was like he's 20
months i'm like oh my gosh yeah and now
it's all he does that boy will probably
be a wrestler now birdie wants to be a
singing scientist so i don't know if
that will change yeah but um see i see
matteo and the dancing the stars stands
for i do too i see him as a pro like his
dad
[Music]
you